with glass receiving mass critic
screenings and the review embargo being
lifted a week before the film is widely
released I thought I'd weigh up the
general consensus to let you know
whether it's worth seeing next week I'll
also be discussing the box office
predictions for the movie which will
signify whether this is set to resurrect
M night's career or not now as of this
video the film is currently sitting at
39 percent on Rotten Tomatoes with the
Critics consensus reading glass displays
a few glimmers of M night Shyamalan at
his twisty world bending best but
ultimately disappoint as the conclusion
to the writer directors along gestating
trilogy now personally I disagree with
his world bending comment the twists
themselves are quite mundane by
shyamalan standards and the film just
feels well very middle-of-the-road
which I found to be carrying a lot of
goodwill from unbreakable and split and
merely capitalizing on that rather than
providing a worthy succession to it
looking at Brandon Katz from The
Observer it's clear that I'm not alone
in this opinion he states the first half
of glass is a rush arousing payoff for
fans who've been obsessing over this
saga for nearly two decades it's a treat
to revisit David all these years later
touching to see him happily run her home
security store with his son Joseph
during the day and then feed rabid
internet speculation over his alter egos
existence with his prowling nocturnal
vigilantism this showcases that Shamma
Lamma is banking on nostalgia rather
than truly taking the world into a
brilliant brand new direction this plot
device is the best in the movie and is
something that was pretty much
established at the end of the first film
or at least hinted at enough for
audiences to draw that conclusion after
waiting almost 20 years for a sequel to
unbreakable a trilogy that was planned
in the naughties I found the film very
underwhelming with an ending that
disappointed on a number of levels
it was quite head-scratching overall
especially with the thematic
positive note that they tried to end on
that feels very rammed and the P was
thrown Sam Adams of slate said on a
purely practical level glass is drawn
out and disjointed with disparate plot
threads that seem dictated more by its
stars availability than narrative
cohesion this highlights that perhaps it
was wrong to force the split universe to
be one with the unbreakable one and
totally these films feel quite jarring
apart from one another so together it's
a mess which I completely agree with
split is a horror film unbreakable is an
uplifting superhero origin and to me
these two tones just don't mix to great
effect one of the handful of positive
reviews comes from Kristian harloff of
schmoes knows who states a very well
done movie it comes down to whether or
not you liked the ending a good movie
with the disappointing payoff now I
disagree with this I know people who
have watched my ending explained video
or have seen the ending of the film will
already have their own opinions on it
but I struggle to really see how it was
satisfying
now I'm not someone who needs everything
to be tied up in a nice bow my favorite
films are the thing infinity war The
Godfather and Empire Strikes Back and
all of them have dark bitter endings
this however just felt like a misjudging
of what the audience wanted and it's
difficult to imagine how anyone would
have been hoping for an ending like this
anyway it's clear that opinions on the
film are very mixed so how is the film
predicted to do with the emergence of
negative reviews
well IMDB predicts that the film will
generate 280 to 480 million worldwide
but this was based on a rotten tomato
score of 65 to 80 percent with the
underperforming review wise I would
imagine that it would have drastic
effects on the box-office going off the
box-office thread on reddit which was
posted yesterday current estimations
rank it at 45 to 60 million first
weekend
however with a budget of 20 million this
is obviously a big success in terms of
making back its money I'm sure it's not
the success that the studio were banking
on in terms of the film name and
considering the cast list as well as the
success of split but we will just have
to see how it does
squeak when audiences attend the film so
what are your thoughts on the reviews of
glass have you seen it and do you agree
or disagree with them also have these
put you off going to see the film and
how do you think it will perform at the
box office
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and check out my ending explained video
on the film which will be linked at the
end this is a channel for people who are
mad into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]